there's Sun there's sand there's speed
well hold on I'm getting ahead of myself
in 1947 a hundred miles east of LA a
bunch of World War two vets formed a car
club called the Oilers taking their
Model T Fords hot riding them up and
racing them in the Mojave Desert
eventually the men got old the cars
broke down and their brand of
bare-knuckle drag racing all but stopped
until now my name is Mel Stultz
with the race of gentlemen my name is
Bobby green I'm with a race and
gentlemen with the blessing of the
Oilers club founders Mellon Bobby
resurrected the club rebranding it the
race of gentlemen what is the race of
gentlemen it's a vintage car race on the
beach but there's that other layer to it
the race of gentlemen is in a sense a
time travel event we go to great lengths
to make it feel like you could be in a
different time era and the rules of the
race stay true to the time period as
well the body engine and running gear
must be of a certain age and must be
american-made well there's definitely
something American cars all those
incredible cars that we created starting
from let's say the 1910s up until
probably about the 60s we're so
different than anywhere else in the
world things today are made to last a
month the 1932 Ford is made to last
forever it's not just about the cars in
the bikes it's about the camaraderie and
all the things that go in
people are like oh this is so cool
because not only is it a race it's like
a scene it's like a set it's lost in
time and for the race of gentlemen the
love of classic American cars
transcends generations you've got young
kids that want to have a more simple
life and build and make things and then
you've got you know the old generation
we all kind of celebrate that time when
when we built and we did
with our hands the Raceland gentleman is
definitely helping to keep the sport
alive for the new generation